[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
fortnite has dropped yet another update
only one week after the last one
while it may not be huge there's enough
here to predict the future
and delve into some storyline theories
it's now week 8 of season 5. like usual
sit your butt down for 10 minutes slap
code adamaru in the store to support
this series
and let's look at everything that has
changed this week
[Music]
like we could start anywhere else after
the escape pod crash landed in stealthy
stronghold the predator is officially
here right now
it blows my mind the predator is in
fortnite just like the original movie
the predator is hiding in the trees
around stealthy stronghold
waiting to cut you down the predator or
big preds as literally
no one calls him have been brought here
by jonesy
if you are not following fortnite on
twitter here's the audio tease from
earlier this week
complete with a dancing big preds
hashtag
big preds reality log
2053. 105-28
[Music]
i don't think my target knows that i
know
that he knows where i am
which is just where i want him you know
he's been on me for my last dozen jumps
but it's
table turning time because the cat in
this little cat and mouse game
he doesn't know that the mouse
has a knife that's right
the hunter is now the hunted
i lost him well it was nice being a
hunter
if you need me i'll be following in mud
again
but the moment i have the upper hand
it's
welcome to the jungle the predator
is also officially a hunter down at the
haven location
he has his own room which indicates he's
a nice guy when he's not hunting for
trophies
and that reminds me have you seen his
back bling you recognize it right
yeah it's your mum and that's my one mum
joke for the week completed thank you
in the lore of the predator race these
hunters look throughout the universe
for worthy adversaries to battle and
then they take their skulls as a trophy
and back in the 1980s it was annie's
chance to go up against them
by the way i'm thinking of starting an
origin series in which we
retell the official story of each
crossover character that comes into
fortnite
i kinda get the feeling not everyone has
watched an action movie from the 1980s
over in hunter's haven the predator's
room is filled with alien tech
first of all look at the command center
straight from the mother ship
and into fortnite also in the room is
the ceremonial stand which houses all
the gear the predator wears
that includes that iconic mask and
gauntlets
how cool is it that he has a room he's
one of jonesy's original hunters that's
why the walking dead characters
don't have their own home yet the
predator will attack anyone in his
domain with his gauntlet attacks
and hides using this trick the great
thing is
we can take that invisibility mod and
use it ourselves
it lasts for 30 seconds but needs to be
recharged each
use i did a little myth chasing and
concluded that other bosses like mando
can not see you when you are invisible
but they will shoot near the last
location they last saw you
a few more tests on other npcs make this
really complicated sometimes they see
you sometimes they see completely
through you
puns never intended but yeah they will
shoot you or at least
in your general vicinity but sometimes
they're completely oblivious
and here's something extra cool should
you defeat both the boss characters
look at this you can use mando's jetpack
whilst
invisible pretty darn impressive please
do me a favor if you have any
predator-based myths for the grenade
community to chase
please leave them in the comments and
upvote your favorites
speaking of mando each update have you
noticed that mando moves around the
sandy area of the map
each time setting up a new campsite
well a few weeks back mando moved to the
campsite near pleasant park
but for me at least his campsite never
appeared
i've looked around and it totally seems
like it's an issue in my game
but once again in this new update i'm
still unable to find mandel's campsite
please could you let me know if his
official campsite is in your game
and where do you usually find mando for
me he tends to be by the spot nearest
the zero point
like it's his job to protect it from
invading hunters
so the zero point has continued to link
dimensions
and right now two more cracks in time
and space are approaching
up by stealthy stronghold the predator
jungle can be seen
but if the predator is already in the
game
will this be for another hunter maybe
dutch like we talked about last week
but it's the other one i want to talk
about the final dimensional rift is
heading towards
steamy stacks everyone has been
predicting who will appear
some people suggest that lara croft
could be coming to fortnite
imagine lara croft doing take the l
can't wait
but there are other things to consider
theory one
is tenet have you seen the movie yet
tenet is the story of a man
tasked with hunting down a key to
prevent the world from ending
due to time travel sounds familiar right
well think back a season or two and
there was foreshadowing here
deep in the pits of the stacks is a
hidden room with an idol from the tenant
movie
usually easter eggs like this are
removed at the end of the season but
this one continues to this day
what could it mean if you can't be sure
where to find this come to this building
and destroy under the stairs
and finally the wall at the end of the
sub basement
thinking about it this was probably
foreshadowing of
time travel and we never noticed gg
spotlight
theory number two is the terminator my
personal favorite theory
a quick apology from last week i said
that arnie was the t1000
and hundreds of you told me i was
completely wrong he's the t-800
how dare i i'm very sorry but anyway why
is this theory so captivating well let's
break down those clues
clue number one recently content
creators received a package containing
fortnite hunter's goodies and clues
about which characters jonesy wants to
bring to the island
in that package was a set of sunglasses
only a small nod but this is an iconic
thing that annie wears in the terminator
movies
clue number two last week the new
shotgun was added with lever action
the reload method once again referenced
something known in the terminator
universe
and the action the t800 uses when riding
one-handed with a shotgun
as you do i honestly think this looks so
brilliant absolutely badass
but wait there is more clue number three
in the movies the terminator and all the
time travelers are sent back using a
sphere of pure energy
hang on kind of like a zero point and
one in particular arrived at a nuclear
power plant
not to mention most of the terminators
are made using
nuclear power cells and where would you
expect to find one of those
in fortnite at steamystacks right
and clue number four one more for good
luck
the organization behind the ai
revolution is cyberdyne tech
they created skynet which eventually
went on to overthrow the human race
perfect for a child-friendly game it's a
real feel-good
story hold on is that a diplodocus
was ali a trying to tell us something
all those years ago
and to cut this long story short this is
exactly the same walls flaws
doors as cyberdyne in the movies
i think it's safe to say the terminator
is coming to fortnite
very soon bring on the clickbait
thumbnail pictures
the terminators are literal time
traveling hunters
this couldn't fit the theme of the
season more perfectly
so that's why i believe the terminator
is coming and finally we get to see the
terminator face off
with the predator i mean big preds is
anyone saying that yet
no well i'm not going to stop put that
aside now is the right time to practice
your arnie impressions ready for the new
skin
come on do it you got to do the
impressions
god this is my life
let's recap a few other things how about
this
hot watch so i've been keeping an eye
down here
but not recording anything for a video
because i don't really see any
changes but you guys have demanded me to
come back and i'm happy to oblige
i honestly think hot watch chapter 2 is
now complete
and it became a big shots diner i was
hoping for something more monumental but
eating and drinking
are important right the hut has books
and magazines with a few nods to
fortnite characters
but i honestly don't think this is being
updated anymore
rip the dream so unless something
happens here this
is the end of hut watch i know you're
crying right now i am too
but all good things must come to an end
the hut has been part of our lives for
years
goodbye hot watch thank you for the
memories
so i believe that's it in terms of map
updates that's week eight of chapter two
season five
a quick thank you and a huge i'm sorry
to the people who've used my code
adamaru
in recent weeks i haven't been active
enough in my twitter dms and i'm very
sorry
i'll be putting that right this week so
expect a reply
very soon i'm adam from playstation
grenade it's been a pleasure
i'll see you next time
you